[Music]
in this video we shall take a look into
the biggest sea monsters in fiction
we shall include all the monsters from
movies games and other fictional works
just to give you a hint monsters like
the octalis the meg
and the mosasaurus which are around 80
feet long or 24 meters
are too small to be in the list as well
as the pirates of the caribbean kraken
which is 130 to 160 feet long or between
40 to 50
meters as well as the demo king and even
lizzy from rampage which
hit the 60 meters or almost 200 feet
mark are still not in this ranking
so take notes fam as these titanic
creatures are well
bigger than the titanic itself so let's
get it on
at number 15 we have the kraken standing
towering over an ancient greek city on
the cliffs
near the sea this monster from the
remake of the clash of the titans movie
was nearly 120 meters tall
or 400 feet in height it was a gigantic
creature that allied itself with the
greek gods to battle against the titans
and with its help they were able to
subdue their enemies
in the movie it was summoned from the
depths of the ocean to punish the humans
that were desecrating and defying the
gods it was however defeated by perseus
using the head of medusa
to turn it into stone at number 14 we
have the bewilder beast
although this next title class dragon
was shorter than the kraken
its length exceeds the previous ranking
it was stated to be 520 feet long or
158.5 meters
they are massive alpha class dragons
that appeared in how to train your
dragon two
and three they are incredibly massive
they are spiky dragons with a pair of
gigantic dust-like horns
protruding from the sides of their heads
and also multiple wings that they use
for swimming
but its most notable and feared ability
is its extremely cool
icy breath number 13 we have the sea
emperor leviathan
next we have this entry from the game
subnautica and these monsters called the
sea emperor leviathans
can live up to 2 600 years this
leviathan is colossal having a stocky
entirely armored body
and is predominantly pale brown in color
with shades of green
its tentacles are adorned with bright
cyan bioluminescent bulbs
and this monster swims using its
numerous tentacles from the back that
are squid like
its length is between 160 to 200 meters
long
or between 520 to 660 feet
number 12 we have the sando aqua monster
on this spot we have this gigantic
monster from
episode 1 of star wars the phantom
menace they were enormous
muscular predators that could be found
in the oceans and lakes of naboo
although they could grow up to 200
meters they were rarely seen
measuring between 160 to 200 meters in
length normally
or the same as the previous ranking the
sando aqua monsters owed their name to
their gigantic size
and they are the apex predators of their
world
number 11 godzilla and destoroyah on the
11th spot we have decided to place two
of the most iconic kaiju created by
touhou
destroyer from the 1995 movie godzilla
vs destoroyah
and legendary's monster verse 2019
godzilla
both these kaiju are similar in height
standing on the ground they are both 120
meters or 400 feet tall
but their overall length including their
very long tails
they are estimated to be between 230 to
240 meters long
or around 800 feet titanic's gojira is
an ancient aquatic super species
but destoroyah originated from a
microscopic sea animal
number 10 the pacific rim kaiju and
sladen
now we come to the top 10 and on this
ranking we have clubbed together the
pacific rim
kaiju and although there are many which
are smaller than godzilla and destoroyah
there are a couple which have exceeded
their size and since the mega kaiju has
never taken to the sea
slatten will be considered on this list
as a representative of the group
this category 5 kaiju dwarfs even the
biggest
diegas on the movie and it was 274
meters or almost 900 feet long
number nine cthulhu making its way from
lovecraft's worlds this great old one
was originally from space
but for millions of years he has resided
in the depths of the pacific ocean
in an ancient city called raleigh
cthulhu's appearance is that of a
colossal humanoid entity possessing both
dragonic anthropoetic and cephalopodic
qualities the most notable feature is
its head
which was humanoid but also has an
octopus like
feature with many tentacles it could
grow to whatever size it wants to
and the biggest was around 300 meters or
1000 feet tall
number eight caribbes another greek
monster on this list this character is
taken from percy jackson in the
olympians part 2 movie
she is one of the sea monsters guarding
the bermuda triangle
also known as the sea of monsters and it
is due to her that there have been
hundreds of ship disappearances in the
region
and all the boats that have gone into
the sea ends up being swallowed by her
she was seen to be hundreds of meters in
size and that was just a mouth
seen in the movie number seven the
leviathan from mass effect
this is the second leviton on the list
and there will be another one as well
the leviathans are ancient aquatic rays
that dominated the galaxy in the time
before the reapers
in the game mass effect they regard
themselves as the galaxy's first and
only apex rays
and they think of other races as mere
tools meant to serve them
the leviathans are massive in size
around one to two kilometers or
0.6 to 1.2 miles and possess a
resemblance to cuttlefish and squid but
heavily armoured
number 6 the korathan a coming from the
dc extended universe movie aquaman
the karate is an original concept and
was long thought to be merely a creature
of legend
in the movie many atlanteans believed
that the grathan served as a guardian
beast of the ocean
but in the later scenes of the movie
aquaman discovered it guarding the
trident of atlan
in the hidden sea garathan resembles a
combination of a squid
a shrimp and a dragon and the vfx artist
stated that it was about 2 miles or 3.2
kilometers long
number five euroman gander the world
serpent of norse mythology has its
appearance in the game god of war 4.
also called jarman gander this gigantic
serpent was extremely colossal in size
and it aided craters and atrias in the
fight against the norse gods
it was essentially a big white sentient
snake that was destined to fight thor in
the prophecy of ragnarok
reddit users and god of war fans have
tried and the most acceptable figure is
that
german ganor is around 3 miles or 5
kilometers long
number 4 the cloverfield monster this
spot goes to the monster from
cloverfield and cloverfield paradox
movies
and the clever monster was an ancient
amphibious organism awakened by the
drilling of a japanese station
and oil platform which had the purpose
of extracting a substance
for a drink called slusho the creature
was only 1200 feet long in the first
movie
but in a second it was seen towering
above the clouds over an ocean
which means it was anywhere between five
to eight kilometers stall
number three scp-3700 one and two
on the third spot we have two giant scp
monsters from the north sea between
the islands of great britain and iceland
one of these called scp-3701 resembles a
lobster
but it is six kilometers long and has
six arm-like limbs which include four
claws
and two clubs and is heavily armored
scp-3702 looks like a pelican eel
and has several tentacles on his body it
is 32 kilometers long
and this creature has a head that is
three kilometers wide
and both of them battle each other twice
a year in the north sea
number two scp-3000 ananda sasha
so another one on this list is a
gigantic sap entity called ananta sasha
or officially classified as scp-3000 it
is a massive aquatic
serpentine entity strongly resembling a
gigantic mori eel
the full length of scp-3000 is
impossible to determine
but it is hypothesized to be between 600
and 900 kilometers long
the head of scp-3000 alone measures only
2.5 meters in diameter
and the sections of the body proper are
as large as 10 meters in diameter
number one scp-169 the leviathan
and the biggest of them all is yet
another scp entity called the leviathan
or scp-169
it is magnitudes larger than even the
second one in the second spot
it is so nice to be a marine arthropod
of enormous size
known as the leviathan by generations of
sailors and oral history
it is suggested that scp-169 is located
in the southern atlantic ocean
possibly stretching around the tip of
south america its total length is
anywhere between two thousand
and eight thousand kilometers and so
with that we come to the end of this
list of the biggest sea creatures from
fiction
if you have more of these do put them
down in the comments section below
and we will see if we can make another
15 biggest fictional sea monsters part 2
video
anyway do hit that like and subscribe
button for more videos in the future and
also smash the notification bell for
regular updates